correspond to all the different forces
completely cancel
so when i sum over all the currents
okay
um i sum of all the anomalies it turns
out that they it vanishes in the
standard wall so that's what makes our
standard model quite unique actually
mathematically
that it counts as anomaly so that's
another place charlene simon's theory
shows up
okay
and then the
the other place that shows up is
actually in string theory and string
theory the churn simon's theory shows up
to actually actually
in a magical way it also plays a role in
canceling the anomalies and string
theory as well
it's called a green schwarz mechanism
right right right current simon's
gravity now is another place um that i
played um a role in
in
pushing over my career as um
a way of a new way of another
oh a way of thinking about gravity that
has the turn simon's term in it
can we go back to the other page where
we have the anomaly
this one before that
okay
see oh my god this is a mess i need to
yeah that's fine okay you can
see on the right hand side
what an anomaly is is when there's a
violation of the conserved current but
i'm unsure is that all that anomalies
are are there other types of anomalies
other than quantum anomalies in other
words whenever someone says there's an
anomaly are they always referring to
that the right-hand side is no longer
zero
very good so let me um
good question so let me just say another
in general if i this is a general
statement i'm making about anomalies
okay for any current
um that is conserved that's right that
is conserved
um
i'm going to put on the right hand side
the letter a if it's not if it's not
equal to 0 and there's an a
that a is called the anomaly that's
literally what it means
so when a is 0 then the current is
conserved and
the question you're asking is can an
anomaly arise um
in a non-quantum way
um that's a good question i you know um
um
so one thing
the calculations that are done to
determine the anomaly to my knowledge
are all
um are all quantum
um considerations
um but i see no reason why you can't you
know in some
theory which i can't recall right now
generate an anomaly classically